لذلك ربما لا يكون مسافر الرحلات البحرية اليوم
هو الشخص الذي يعتقده معظم الناس هو أنك
تعرف أن هناك هذا القول المأثور الرهيب
الذي مفاده أن الإبحار هو
للمتزوجين حديثًا الذين يعانون من الإفراط في تناول الطعام وأن الموتى تقريبًا ليس صحيحًا
على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]
من المتوقع أن يقوم أكثر من 30 مليون شخص
قم برحلة بحرية في عام 2020
وفقًا لجمعية Cruise Lines
International Association ، لذا فإن ما
تفعله الصناعة لإبقاء
الناس متحمسين بشأن الإبحار لشيء واحد
قد ذهب الآن إلى أبعد من
ألواح المراوغة وهو تحويل السفينة من
وسيلة نقل إلى وجهة
لا تقوم بها الرحلات البحرية  لم يعد يقدم سوى تجربة واحدة
للجميع ، وفي عام 2020 ،
من المقرر أن يحقق خطان جديدان للرحلات البحرية أقصى استفادة من
علامتهما التجارية الراسخة بالفعل ، حيث تقدم
ريتز كارلتون
علامتها التجارية الفاخرة أساسًا في البحار سواء كانت صغيرة أو
حميمة ولكن بالطبع مع فندق
ريتز  - تلمس كارلتون رحلات فيرجن وهي
تجلب سفينة أكبر قليلاً
تبحر من ميامي ابتداءً من
أبريل إلى منطقة البحر الكاريبي ، إنهم بالغون
فقط  إنهم يتخلصون من
مفهوم غرفة الطعام الرئيسية ، فهم يجلبون
صالونًا للوشم ، إنه عصري وحديث ،
وبالطبع ريتشارد برانسون في كل مكان
تحاول شركات الرحلات البحرية منذ فترة طويلة
معالجة أكبر
انتقاداتهم للسكان المحليين والموانئ الصغيرة
والسفن الكبيرة المفجرة ، قائلين  الضيوف الذين شرعوا في
رحلات برية يكتظون بالبلدات الصغيرة
وعلى الرغم من أن العديد من السفن الجديدة تتجه إلى
وقود محترق أنظف وتحسين
طريقة معالجتهم لمياه الصرف الصحي ، لا تزال الصناعة
تكافح لتحسين سمعتها
لكونها قاسية على البيئة